I wouldn't make it right this time
because you've written it like 20 times
but this whole time we've been - you
have four different kinds of chronic
sections that come when you vary the
values of the eccentricity right so we
know these two death right now so I'm
not even gonna say anything else about
them but what I asked was okay what's
actually going on and in particular why
is the order of the shapes circle
ellipse parabola hyperbola what's
actually visually happening - so far we
haven't really connected this idea we've
said it's a ratio yeah but doesn't have
much to do with the actual like these
are something to do with cones so the
question is what right so therefore how
I got a picture this right now I am
actually going to ask you to draw
something for me which is okay at the
very beginning we define for ourselves
what products were there's a conic
section of the conic section which is
sought for cross section of the code
right and you can kind of see some of
these are easier than others and you'll
have to draw really well here I'm going
to try and draw intersection right by
imagining a plane that cuts through the
cone planes of 2d shapes turns a 3d so
I'm gonna get a cross-section so he so
I'm gonna draw it okay so what you try
and imagine that thing slicing right
through the middle okay now this is the
first time I'm going to draw and then
I'm gonna bring out some props but
because it's quite easy it's literally
right across if I wanted to say it would
be parallel to the plane that is it's
parallel to the base of the cone okay so
what kind of shape are we going to get
from here we're gonna get a circle okay
because I could cut the current if I cut
it parallel in that way I'll get a whole
bunch of circles
really small ones up here and then
they'll keep on going until you get to
the bottom which itself is also a circle
no problems okay now that's where we
started so last time we looked at this
thing we looked at this thing right and
we had a look at what happens when we
started with the eccentricity being
really little and that's why we had that
quiet circular looking shape right I can
make this a bit brighter there we go
okay and then as we increase the
eccentricity what happened well there we
go
a shape became more and more fat it
became more of an ellipse it always was
OOP some went too far okay so we had
this kind of thing happening right now
therefore what's changing with regard to
the current how do I get these kinds of
shapes out of the kind well I can't cut
it in the same way can i how would I
have to cut it how would change I'm
gonna have to anyway I cut it across
I'll still get a circle but the way I
can get an elliptical kind of shape he's
by cutting it at a different angle case
enjoy yourself another curve right now
this is where unfortunately paper is
gonna let us down a little bit because
we can try to draw this but we very hard
to do well so I'm gonna try and draw
something like this okay so I'm getting
it going across at an angle right now if
you picture in your mind having a
current there and taking a knife and
slicing it across I don't know if you
guys are on it's a traditionally Asian
sort of thing where if you have a the
other cucumber right instead of cutting
out across like that and getting circles
right yeah agents achieve so we're like
you know we want to make it look like
the key comes up bigger than they really
are so you cut it in diagonals now you
can sort of even see off the diagonals
but what you're going to get is gonna be
longer see it's longer right but I
haven't changed the diameter the height
of the cucumber if you like so what's
gonna come out is something that's
longer but it's it's
well it's a little cool isn't it okay so
this is how the shape would look it'll
be offered an angle okay yeah I told you
the paper that you down so I brought
something that wouldn't so here you go
here's a cone okay
and there's my cucumber slice can you
see it right it's elliptical because I
went off at an angle
okay now sense tells you that as we
change the angle right now you've got
sort of what's the angle this vampire
it's pretty high I don't know maybe 70
degrees or 60 degrees or something like
that okay and this angles looks like
kind of 45 or so feels like that's where
it would mean but as I increase that
angle and make it steep up okay the
shape you're going to get is different
right we started with a circle then
we've got this elliptical kind of thing
and at some point well what happens and
what's point for yourself another color
at some point these ends don't connect
anymore right and that particular point
is where you've gone so far that instead
of being a plane parallel to the base
this one I plan just being off an angle
this plane is parallel to the slamfire
do you see that not just from one Y but
the whole plane itself okay so you're
going to get this kind of shape it
doesn't reconnect at the end right it
should look something like which one is
that look about right there's a slant
height look of parallel to the plane can
you see it
and they go there's the shape okay and
that's the problem of the we're familiar
with right yeah okay so we have one last
case to consider the one that we just
most recently been looking at right so
what's the logical conclusion they're
forced there
people who went to the you met evening
let's complete the pattern if I was
parallel to the base off at an angle
often named or swim parallel to the
slant height what's my last one going to
be now here's the thing right remember
look at these these values correspond to
something here wherever I said for these
to get a second your plate has to be
flat exactly flat not a little bit off
has to be flat which corresponds is that
there's only one value for eccentricity
that will give you a circle okay
now here you've got a bit range right
you can have more circular ellipses or
you can have fat ellipses depending on
how you slice the cucumber right so
that's correspond to the fact they have
a range of values for the eccentricity
and I can change that angle if I like
right here it looks as though you could
get a whole bunch of different parabolas
but what we know about the pattern so
far is that you can't there's only a
single kind of flame right I see what
angle for this plane has to be exactly
parallel that'll really give you a
parabola okay so what does this suggest
how many angles can I put that plane at
together
the answer is I should be able to do a
whole ton right like more than just a
single value and this thing about okay
an easy classic way to think about it is
just to make it vertical okay what kind
of shape are you gonna get well you
start from this end you're gonna be like
hold on I feel ripped off that's not
hyperbola that's hard hyperbola right
you need two of them
okay make sure you at the orientation to
me now unfortunately these don't connect
together so I'm just gonna have the
whole thing really going but there's a
double cone okay can you see it there
you go
so if I spin it around there's the
hyperbola shape that we're familiar with
now what happens
how would I get different kinds I'll
have people with different eccentricity
where would the plane go you change it
in a couple different ways you can move
it around like for instance if I moved
you're looking at it there right so
you're kind of off to the side but I can
move I can move this plane horizontally
can't I right if I move it in can you
see these two points it by the way this
distance it has a name we used to see it
this way that's the transverse axis
right the transverse axis is gonna get
smaller right it still be a hyperbola
okay so we can change that by changing
this horizontal position okay
alternatively we could still be offered
a different angle so long as we're not
exactly parallel to the slant height
right through there yeah yeah good
question
excellent question what would happen um
where picture excuse me two cones a
double cone if you like so if my plane
do you go right through the middle
if it's going right through the middle I
guess these things should touch
shouldn't they hmm but what kind of
shape would I get if you can matte it
carefully think about it really
carefully look at the car okay remember
if I cut it right through the middle
right through the middle okay what's it
gonna look like you're slicing it huh
aren't you now we're gonna draw this in
a second but I think I can do something
very I said that the board and your
paper would let you down right because
you're trying to do 2d and this is
better this is an improvement okay but
it's also letting us down because this
is one ellipse and one of those only but
we're trying to think about things as
they change right okay so let me see if
I can do this you might like to H
forward now this is the one I want okay
let me try and make it as big as I can
okay how many of you can see that being
can you see it can you make it up let me
try I can make a little there we go okay
okay good can see it so there's the
double cone okay
now have a look at what's there right
now you can see there's a little red
shape what is that that's a circle
because what kind of plane do I have
which one of these is it it's parallel
to the basis of it so does that first
case okay for what kinds of things can I
do here this is the first all right I'm
going to score off I'm going to vary for
instance where I am vertically okay so
I'm going to think about these cases now
what would you expect to happen the size
of the circle the magnitudes radius
should change right so let's go okay
that's good down shall we good and as we
get to the base if I get to the base
there you go there's the biggest circle
like that makes and I can go all the way
up and if I can keep my grip and
different circle
great okay come back down to the bond
code
all right now what if I try and move
across here right I need to change the
angle at which the plane is cutting the
cone okay so let's try and move this guy
over a little bit okay you see it
happening how's my can you guys actually
see the screen so now you can see oh
there we go there's our ellipse
okay now hold on a second I said there's
a whole range of values here and it's
fairly single one we actually get to a
parabola so here's my question what if I
move to say there okay now you can't
read it but another probably but my
rotation angle is 33 degrees at those so
that's the angle off from the from the
base right now pretty sure they've drawn
this cone so the slam hey is at 45
degrees so it's nice and even so I've
got a plane at 33 and a little slant
height of 45 right now what kind of
shape does that look like
it does look like a parabola doesn't it
but you're being fooled okay I'll tell
you why you're being full if I have okay
no let's try this I should've brought
something longer with me but I'm gonna
make a shape here okay and I want you to
tell me what you think it looks like
okay let's see okay there's an easy
shape what's that what kind of line is
it's a straight line okay so it's a
linear function okay
all right now I'm gonna put it down to
about let's do clearly this thing's been
in too many knots but imagine it a
little bit smoother okay what kind of
shape does that look like doesn't look
like a problem doesn't it but it's not
it's not you can take a shape you can
take a picture of it you can try and
match a parabola to it and you'll get
close but you'll never get there because
this shape is not a parabola completely
different it's cool I think it's a
continuing it's the shape of an object
that's hanging under its own weight it
looks like a parabola really does but
it's not and the mass will prove it
okay now this thing also looks like a
problem why why does it look like a
parabola I think the only reason it
looks like a parabola and not like the
ellipses we got before is because is
because it stops it ends it's not um
it's not full it doesn't come back round
on itself right but if you look really
closely imagine if I drew this kind of
shape
okay now suppose you knew actually still
horizontally because that'd be a bit
easier for em that suppose I could tell
you without a shadow of doubt
okay but differentiating or inspection
or whatever that the tangent yeah I
missed the tangent here and the tangent
now on science fiction it looks like a
parabola doesn't it because again like
the shape we you just looked at it
doesn't complete doesn't come back
around okay but you can tell me it's not
a parabola why not
what's the reason can we can we
articulate it cuz it cuz of replicant
what probably Conn parabolas have this
kind of equation right so when you
differentiate them you're going to get a
function like that okay and no matter
how far you go with this parabola okay
putting the largest values of x that you
like you will get very very high but
you'll never get to what kind of
gradient would correspond to these kinds
of things for these are to be zero right
so I guess I'm thinking with the other
way around
X's and Y's swap for this it'll be there
would be no gradient because vertical
isn't it the proper can never get there
so I know that is Shane even though it
doesn't come back around it's actually
not a problem it's really part of an
ellipse it's just I don't have enough of
a cone to show me the ellipse okay does
that make sense
so you can talk about the curvature the
curvature tells you all right now I'm
almost done that was the that was the
ellipse yeah okay what do I need what do
I need in order to get a real parabola
well I said this night happens 45 good
night okay okay and you're like really I
can hardly see a difference
okay so to us to allies we can't tell
the difference right but this is one of
the great things about maths right you
don't need to trust your eyes eyes you
can trust the equations and you see
what's going on right in fact when we do
these when we try to tell we know the
equations are completely different right
something might look parabolic right but
we know it from the equation it's gonna
with y squared in it's a copy okay right
there's my problem last one let's have a
good right to fortunate what angle
should I give you that's good we go too
far okay so you can see it cutting
through both ways right you can also see
you don't necessarily have symmetry
between these what would that correspond
to like this part and this part are not
equal what would that mean for a
hyperbola we could draw it does match
the conditions
rahowa sure looks like a like a
hyperbola right so far all the shapes
we've been doing we've been imagining
quite nice and neat right so things like
this I'm saving that one for a rebate
touching things like this you know
because they're easy cases for us okay
so everything's nice and symmetrical but
there's tons of places where there isn't
that kind of symmetry right I can just
move this across maybe I'll just do the
answers there you go it's still
happening
it's just as hot boiling as before I
haven't changed but it's not equal okay
the branches are okay very last question
let's come back to your mate Trisha how
what's gonna happen if we go right
through the middle like good middle now
see if I can do it here well let's let's
see if we can try to get one I want it
to be
now quorum second let me go back a
little bit there we go okay so now I'm
cutting across I'm quitting this run
going vertically okay and you can see
the shape there but I want you to tell
me see if you can describe for me if you
can see it well enough not only the
branches of the hyperbola getting closer
to each other but they're changing in a
particular way right so let's see if I
can move this slowly enough for you to
tell me you can probably see the change
about there can you see do you need me
to go back what's the difference if I
were to draw these if I were to put
these on the same graph here we go okay
I'm gonna increase the Exeter City all
right now have a look at that guy
right and as it increases they do get
closer together but have a look at the
lines we said this before do you
remember they don't look so occur be
anymore in fact that this far the
further I go the less curvy they get as
they as they approach each other
me as a transverse axis gets smaller
then necessarily the lines they get a
lot straighter in fact if you if I cut
it that it almost doesn't look curved at
all it looks like two straight lines
does it they're approaching the
asymptotes right now when I actually get
two together
it breaks okay if I were to cut these
exactly in half we've been saying that
they're going to get straight up and
straight up and straight up and straight
up eventually
big announcement because that's what the
cross-section of two coins looks like if
you go right down the middle because
you're chopping it enough look it see
this
there's the comb and there's the other
one okay Nevernever we can't get there
it breaks down in a similar way but this
breaks down this is really just an idea
it's it's really the limit the limit as
T approaches